okay so we are here to talk about multi
way system and for people who are in our
previous life stream I apologize for not
getting to your comments we will get to
them in the next live stream on that
series about entity objects
okay so multi way systems are proving to
be very valuable in physics but also
valuable for lots of other purposes and
we want to try to mainstream them and
get them into the main system so we have
a functional posit or e function which
has you know one thing that I am so
confused by in these in these summary
tables for function depository items
there's you know it's not showing the
full depth of what's underneath there
see that there's much more there can we
um who's appearing here yes okay so you
understand what I'm saying that this
doesn't look like it's a complete
picture of what's underneath yeah
and the question is for the for the
folks who are dealing with the
documentation why is that happening I
mean you can only be so I mean it can
only fit for page widths of stuff I know
that but what it should be the top and
then it should have a dot dot dot that's
what we had agreed previously if it's
the last one no yeah right
okay okay so okay let's
about Nesta graph first because nest
graph is very close to multi way system
it isn't quite an S cough has some
infuriating little loose ends I mean so
for instance if I say um nest graphed
hash plus 3 comma hash plus 5 ampersand
start from 0 5 steps I got some
beautiful thing like this right
but Nesterov has some corner cases that
are completely bonkers and the question
is what what is different between multi
way system and nest graph alright so let
me show you certainly they're a bunch of
certainly they're just a bunch of
differences with you know different
output forms right where the edge is
annotated with which rule it used and
stuff like that right which will be very
useful for so for nest graph one can
imagine no since it's always coming out
from a list here but both who do we have
here who is responsible for Nesta graph
okay Charles ok so right now these edges
are untagged right well they can't
possibly be tagged because the the
function just returns a list they decide
which which number which element of the
list came from that edge you know
produced that edge well I think this is
one of the things that makes Nesta graph
difficult is that I'm pretty sure it has
no usage where you give it a list of
functions and since so instead it has
two kind of voodoo around to figure out
whether this thing that you returned
basically how to unpack it right and for
example if you have a single element but
that single element happens to be a list
than their problems and stuff like that
so I mean I think that the I guess you
can rely on which element of the list is
being returned but you don't even know
if the same number of elements being
returned that's okay you know
computation examples what so long so
long as this is I mean I could say
something like you know if even Q hash
you know I don't know hash plus one
otherwise this well but I think by the
way you don't even have to put the hash
plus one in a list it will magically
figure it out that's one of the things
that's strange
I'm pretty sure yeah seems to be true yo
so I think that has a corner case
consequence but things which are
analysts that goes crazy what I mean
there is I mean does not they sing new
or specific to NASCAR feet there is the
general you know fact that we need to
make a distinction between a list of
vertices or a vertex itself or a list of
a tasty dishes actually vertex into a
framework you have been working on it we
have to balance between the performance
and that you know so there is those
cases and we have example for next graph
you hope to fix later on well what's the
design when you give a list well there
is not per se design it's just that we
need to know the way you specified if
you know if you give a list like in this
case is a function which the first you
know the first assess the list we assume
that that list is you know he's actually
a vertex is not a list of vertices so
and is actually more a matter of
implementation because I generally we do
some flattening and so Martin for
efficiency and then you know you have
the issue with you know the stability in
general so I'm confronted I guess for
multi way system now you could have
something where you just you just
require that whatever you're returning
being a list right because then that way
if you're returning a even if you're
returning only a single argument you
know that should be wrapped in list
because then that means that if that
single argument happens to be a list
you survived better which is the
unambiguous case with nest graph so I
think that's what produces some of the
confusion is that nest graph accepts the
you know if you give it if you just
return a number it's unambiguous though
you can just wrap that and the listener
will work but then the problem is is
when when people then try and return
lists because it works for individual
number so it might work for a list as
well because it's just an expression
but then interprets a list in a special
way Bindu yeah if any divisional design
why he take the second argument is an
expression that is pushed on Connie
Sylvia lists which is ambiguous
this is why recently this is why we
disambiguate the list and Wolfram model
cases in the implementation of multi way
system right so you require that it be
wrapped in a you you know you require
that that that for a multi way system
that you return a list of elements right
right right but the point is because
there because there are two canonical
systems that operate at list depths of
two and three for the list step three
case we require that you specify that
case explicitly because otherwise it's
dangerous to infer it for precisely this
reason okay
well wait a minute this is a case where
hmm so you see such lines you see my
point right you if if you if you see a
list of depth three generically in a
multi way system implementation you
don't know whether that's a list of
Lists substitution initial conditions or
a single wolfram model initial condition
mm-hmm can it not I mean presumably you
can you can well okay I don't know how
the how the current multi way system
function works but I thought that it was
also kind of just a purely general thing
you just give it an expression and some
functions and we'll figure it out I know
it is but then in order to implement the
shorthands you have to have some way of
specifying which case you're talking
about but but so I mean presumably
though right if I want to use this
function to map over something and I'm
gonna use right you you don't want it so
that the shorthand happens to collide
with the data structure I'm used
that I want to write to lover so to
speak right so look we've got this
string substitution thing so what we
could do here is to require that
everything has a wrapper select for the
strings case we could require the
wrapper substitution system which of
course internally is what we do all
right fair enough
seems like the system thing to do as I
say in the agenda the canonical form is
you know is string arrow rules I know
which I think we better it were if it
was you know a wrapper and which we can
do once we have a wrapper for what model
for example yeah this is what I wanted
to discuss that exactly how it's going
to work that you want to implement a
system version of multi way system
without implementing a system version of
walking model that seems extremely messy
to me right well is there a reason not
to implement a system version of wolf
model yeah no it's just that you you
said on whatever the meeting where we
did we discussed this where we discussed
the current meeting you said it made
more sense to implement multi bit system
than to implement or from model because
you were worried about either you or max
I forget we're worried about burning in
the sort of structure of Wolfram model
too early yeah well I mean it doesn't
have to support like look again if you
just allow I mean if it supports the
general case then you can just use the
function repository function Wolfram
model and you know and then maybe if
multi rate system has optimizations for
Wolfram model then you know maybe it can
do a little bit of a hacky thing and it
can see you know because if it's looking
at the wrappers for the functions to do
optimizations that come looking if the
function is a string substitution system
it can look for a resource function as
well right right although we there are
some significant issues that I faced
with having resource function wrappers
to do with mismatched contexts and
things but we may be able to hack around
that
okay well isn't the Wolfram model
function already in in the function
repository you know yeah it is the issue
is when you call if you call a Wolfram
model wrapper at least with the resource
function version of multi-way system I
don't know if it'll be different if you
call it
from system but there are issues with
which you know what context the resource
function is in what versus what context
multi-way system is in that sure yeah I
haven't yet been able to find it an on
hacky solution - right I mean he doesn't
have to actually call the resource
function you can just see the head
resource function of quotes Wolfram
system whatever it's called right okay
all right so let's look alright so I've
got a question immediately which is
changing nest graph to tag its edges is
there a reason not to do that
I mean it's just it's it's very
undefined because I think that like look
you could do with the index but then I
guess I also feel returning Association
and maybe you could support that case as
well although I don't think that's
currently supported about supporter
trolls
no okay I mean that seems like it if I
mean it's mostly nice though if you do
this this edge labeling thing but why
would it tag thee what would it tag the
edges with I mean the end across
sociation the key okay the other
question is what happens about multi
edges what what does nest Gough do with
multi edges right now I believe it it
elides them doesn't it I mean region if
I do coffee damage apologies reach in
there a them I don't think there is no
you don't look at that I think that to
correct me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty
sure that nest graph does not does not
assume that that the function is
deterministic right so so if for example
you know if I have some function that I
don't know let's say I'm doing like that
example from the documentation where
like it finds synonymous words or
something like that right and it makes
that Network so if I you know give it
the word you know whatever fish and
finds synonymous words and then one of
those words is also you know back
synonymous to fish that I think it
checks for synonymous words to fish
again right
doesn't say oh I've already been to this
vertex I don't need to check it that
right because yes that's correct because
actually I mean one of the first I've
been at the time when we build netskope
one of the thought was essentially to
build a caller so if you are traversing
a website or such a thing 5s again the
link twice you don't count you know you
don't you know it's add multiple II know
multiple edges and we considered you
know at some point that maybe we should
have an option where somebody can't
specify that right so that you want to
generate your graph and take into
account multiple edges or not so we just
have a look multiple what's the
analogous option multi leg system for
multiple edges include event instance is
true okay so I mean there are two things
here look the multi edge case we really
would like that really will be useful
for NASA graph I mean the
non-determinism is a different issue
from the multi edges right yeah what's
this oh wait let me let me just clarify
one other thing though so if you know
for example if you write the web crawler
case does that will it ever visit the
same web site twice like in the sense
will it ever
you know if I'm doing a web crawler and
I start it you know google.com will it
if it happens to loop back around will
it again ask for the you know hyperlinks
out of Google calm or well it's a I've
already been here here Alaska these
demos implementation he will just ask
you more I think we should have an
option for whether does that because I
think mathematical cases where you
absolutely do not want that again the
determinism thing all right so there's
an assumed determinism versus not I mean
I assume that's the only reason why you
care about it hey maybe there's some
other comes in I mean if there's a
random number look if I put in here
that's gonna make a total mess
I don't even know what'll thing is you
see that some of these have an out
degree of three or of greater than 2
what does that mean so it returned to
that place yeah and then I ran it again
I assume mm-hmm yeah right is that right
Charles
um yes okay whereas if it had cashed it
it would not do that right there by the
way there is a question of if you if you
if you have this option that that word
includes the multiplicity is will it if
it's doing this caching how should the
should it calculate what the
multiplicities would have been had it
not cached or should it just give you
the multiplicities you know with the
caching so to speak I don't know it's
time but what do you mean okay so so so
when we were talking about before is
that the issue of adding more edge
multiplicities for multigraphs
right so I suppose it goes in a giant
loop and it goes around the swoop 500
times since you have a 500 thick you
know multi edges right so the question
is how does it interact with this
because if I say this is deterministic
even cache does that mean that it should
not include that 500 multi-edge because
it would never do that because it would
just you know it would just realize it's
wasting time or should it rely or or
should it calculate how what the
multiplicities wanted to calculate what
they would have been and the caching is
only the question of whether you make
the assumption that you don't it's an
optimization you know yeah okay so you
know basically it's almost a method
option you know deterministic or
something method um
I think it's useful to know sometimes
all the multiplicity service culture or
which so if you if you have a multi-way
system which you assume I mean is
deterministic mm then you don't care to
return the same past multiple times but
you might still clear if to evolution
functions you have pretty sure the same
is out I didn't understand it the import
of that so yeah do I don't have you know
any you know really good reason to
reject the caching or such but I believe
it is it goes down too much in the
implementation and expectation behavior
for a next curve on whatever assuming is
that well you know the Internet is a
cough you applied needs graph you
traverse the website so what we are
doing is just the basic reversal II but
first and we just keep traversing we
don't do any tree Chris you know based
on the implementation will affect the
output then it does this is not going to
be I hadn't even remembered that we
built this for website traversal this
funds being used I mean even even for
website traversal though right if you if
you assume that the hyperlinks aren't
changing then you don't want to traverse
the website twice right I mean even for
just breath first search it's an you
know comment like they're doing Dijkstra
or something right you sort of set it up
so that you're not going to double
Traverse things that you reach in more
than one way so I think it's you know
this is like a valid auction even just
for breadth-first search what does but
first search to is that yes and no right
because the matter of use on Dino and in
this case you know we I mean the use
here is the multi waste system you want
to build it on top on this graph so
there it is that point of view which is
you know
and definitely we should add that but we
should also make sure that the function
of a main general enough for other
behaviors I know so look the default you
know if we can determine that it's a
deterministic function then we don't
have to worry about them we can just
assume that it's cached right if we can
determine if we can look at the function
and say there's nothing in this function
that could be non-deterministic which we
could readily do I mean you know I think
that that's introducing more kind of
magic into this into this function I
don't think we want well this question
we can say automatic we can have an
automatic setting for the determinism
thing I mean I think it's probably
preserve what it does already in the
default case maybe I'm it doesn't matter
clearly if the function is deterministic
it doesn't matter yeah I'm not sure if
you can always tell fits deterministic
yeah an example is again the web crawl
example if you if you request a website
and you go typer links it's probably
deterministic but it might not be which
is not assume like a sternal input but
if it if it's you know the sum okay um
okay I mean I don't know if there's any
I mean look this is a maybe a more
general thing that we might want which
is just something that looks at a piece
of code and just has you know a
directory of here all the non
deterministic functions I agree I think
they'll be very worthwhile to have as a
pure code analyzer but but there might
be weird stuff like you know maybe it
turns out that dollar processor account
is technically non-deterministic on
Linux in version whatever and you know
well I'll tell you another problem that
simplify might be non-deterministic
because it depends on absolute time oh
god yeah I mean everything that depends
on absolute time right but many things
do I mean because I tons of math stuff
right I mean
you learn out of memory nothing is
deterministic right but I think it's a
um so this is basically deterministic
code q there's the concept there can we
can we put that in an ILD meeting can
somebody take it is it Devin whose p.m.
in here yes yes I can take this okay
let's talk about breadth-first scan just
for a second a function that I have
essentially never used because I
consider it basically unusable which
I'll fight to comment on this I mean I
know use it a nice what's that
I think it's be useful for optimization
purposes these I mean there is civil
side right I mean we reintroduce it we
made it general enough you know with the
event our so John sure you know for some
people are most of the people is too I
mean it's hard to use so you are
considering you know making it simpler
for sure well you know we make a lot of
automation but it's powerful you know
that you can implement play at first and
pretty much out of implementation from
the language well I understand well I I
mean the question I don't think this
design think designers I had at some
time when I was not reviewing these
things because I just don't understand I
mean most this just seems extremely
complicated but max says he's used it
successfully I've used it as well
did you use it I mean other than just
modifying an example that was already
there yes yes I meet me what a function
to works okay Chris well what did you
use it for I don't even remember I mean
but it was it was for something where I
wanted to I remember one time I use I'm
usually a few times one time I used it
because I was just trying to check if
two vertices on a graph would be
connected you know in some certain case
and I realize I could use some other
functions into it but but yeah I mean
but it's not actually that hard to use I
mean they're they're just you know these
different events are fairly well defined
and you know and also fairly standard
and where people talk about like
frontiers and stuff like that okay seems
incredibly complicated to me
Angus fairly straightforward except for
what it returns so I was very confused
by what does it return well I don't
think it does is it it return it return
you it essentially the input of three
take off which essentially should tell
you to play thesis or based on their
indexes alright so if you give that X 1
to n will overturn eww where you know W
1 is you know is a parent or W or VR v16
okay essentially is an efficient
possession of it we documented returns
there is the line there it's you know it
says the photolysis
blah blah blah okay I guess I missed ok
all right let's let's take a look then
at what the rest people are asking what
mother way systems are we should just um
that's a typical multi way system it it
has a set of rules here and at every
step it has the capability to it
generates all possible paths based on
the application of those rules and in
general it can each possible rule
application is considered to be an event
and it can generate lots of sort of sub
graphs that are asserted or not sub
graphs lot lots of alternative graphs
that are based on including event
information somebody asks the question
can it be used in a game tree can it be
used in a game tree it should surely it
can be used in the game tree
I did it gives you the set of moves like
for tic-tac-toe or something you should
be able I mean presumably Nesta graph
can do that too
such a true statement that Nesterov can
give you the tic-tac-toe
um graph in order to generate it what's
that sorry you think it's harder to
generate it than that
yeah I think so I think you have to do
like pruning things like people he's
like what is it red black trees and
stuff like that to do it and you could
make a basic one for sure with nest crap
but I don't think you'd be able to you
know fine because the reflection classic
tree well they're okay
Lisa defined some time I mean there's no
I mean is not to do that that key
function you are giving is not a trivial
one you can actually just define for
again when you're bit sorry game sorry
what do you say I mean giving them given
a board you're gonna take Tac Toe board
I can say what the possible next
tic-tac-toe boards are why can't I just
put that into Nesterov I think you can
that's easy okay alright so then what
what fails my own thing anything fails I
mean I I just thought you were talking
about the classic tic-tac-toe tree is
the is the like optimal move tree oh I
see I've shown about like the 4,000 node
you know all possible I actually I mean
all possible anymore I think if you
don't play optimally there it's a very
big tree actually or a relatively big
tree if you don't you know remove
symmetry and stuff but I don't know I
don't think so I think oh I seem to
remember it's a it's actually I can look
it up I think it was in the uncurse book
or whatever um oh come on
tic-tac-toe net will look for does it
say four thousand five thousand four
hundred and seventy eight nodes um
should be in the function room I mean it
should be in the data repository Devin
that's a small point we might as well
put that in the data repository at some
point chefs here
um okay so what is the difference
ultimately between nest cough a
multi-way system so multi-way system by
default is right now in our function is
just generating the series of states in
what we might call a cosmological rest
frame that what we see here right well
system acknowledges multi-way system
well how does it work though if they're
loops back up okay so that's a good
point that's the difference between the
evolution function and the states graph
the evolution graph in the state's graph
Jonathan do we have a good example of
that um yeah I mean they're a bunch and
I put in the documentation evolution
graph will keep going the state's graph
will loop around yeah right so the
evolution dropping yeah the evolution
graph includes step numbers by default
okay yeah and the spacecraft is not
right so I mean there are many options
here like like come all these things
about putting weights on these edges so
there's a multi graph and there's
weighting both of those for
multiplicities yes as a multiplet those
are well one is waiting yes these are
multiplicities but they're also things
which are how do these work Jonathan
that they're waiting waiting waiting by
event multiplicity includes state path
weights motivates by the number of
distinct paths that lead to a given
state oh I see so it's distinct paths
from the route that lead to that state
yep if you scroll down this an example
of that nice yeah right okay great
and if there's a loop it goes bonkers
yes so state path weights will assume
evolution graphs in general that's a
state's graph but
wants to be the evolutions graph as well
right right but what does it do didn't
we agree that there was some reasonably
sensible thing to do if there's a loop
um I don't think so
IIIi just said we should do the standard
bellman-ford thing and then complain if
there's a loop or just default to using
the evolution graph what is the standard
bellman-ford thing which is to complain
if there's a loop okay fine because you
because all right fire because a you
know in the context of solving all pairs
shortest paths problems if you have a
negative cycle yeah you know a negative
sum cycle then that's you know your
algorithm work terminates so just just I
mean the state's graph will equal the
evolution graph - you know maybe some
details about the internals of how the
vertices are represented as long as
there isn't a loop right right as long
as there's global high publicity
okay so then shouldn't it just shouldn't
it just throw an error if you ask if you
do what it's doing right here where you
ask for the yes the multiplicities when
two states graph it shouldn't the
evolution graph in principle yes but so
the reason I didn't do it that way was
because the include state path weights
and include state weights are more
general than that they don't depend on
what property you are requesting they
are a general option for the whole
multi-way system so in fact you can
demonstrate that if you take that thing
and you do include state path weights
and then you request state weights
rather than states graph you get just a
list of date weight here state weights I
think here okay so then so the so the
point is it doesn't know whether you're
requesting an evolution graph or a
state's graph when you request
everything so it could complain but it
felt more natural just to assume
everything was an evolution graph unless
told otherwise I'm warning message if
you request the state graph on this but
by by the way this is a detail but is
there a reason that's not an association
no okay it presumably went when it's
right when you're not in right not the
Raps reason is the city is the reason
it's not an association is that graphs
generally you know graph weights are
generally passed as lists I believe
Charles controls Gregg yes I'm wrong yes
why they predate associations okay all
right fine but okay so just to get a
sense for I mean the prompt the
pointment okay so there are two
directions of generalization for the
multi way system thing by the way
Stephen sorry if you want to do a more
explicit comparison with Nesta graph I
just sent you it it hasn't been approved
by Wi-Fi yet but I've just sent you the
WFR version of multi wavefunction system
you
which is basically the multi way analog
of nest cough right well okay here's the
thing right so multi way function system
as you originally scoped it doesn't make
a whole lot of sense to me because great
the to answer I mean this kind of
answers the question you were asking
earlier about the relationship between
nest graph for multi-layer system you
know nest graph is just multi way system
if you only specify a state evolution
function or you don't specify anything
else right if you only request things
that require knowing the state evolution
function you just get nest graph so here
if I couldn't do that and then I say
states graph yep you'll get the same as
you would have got from nest graph
well except I get more nicely labeled
things that's very nice I mean I prefer
that I'm gonna use that I've shown
that's just a graph by the way if it's
styling yep yes
but if you run that for six steps and
then do include state pathway I start
include event instances sorry you should
start to see multiplicities which graph
but by the way sorry
is it using just graph layout layered
whatever or something like that or is it
is it specifying the layout itself it's
not specifying anything it's just
default graph layout okay and it will it
will go non layered by the way Charles I
think layered graph plot should default
should not allow itself to go less than
aspect ratio or half unless it is I mean
cuz I think that this is stupid
okay fine what can I do well here look
look I get carry tree of a thousand and
then I say layered graph plot okay and I
get that
so what I do essentially a hundred
percent of the time is say aspect ratio
Roo half when it gets long and narrow
like that Charles do you want to comment
on that see that's a valid point I mean
yes it's yeah we you know I saw you I
maybe I'll look into that okay there
there are some cases by the way where
I'd specifically don't do that because
you know you you have some you you
actually want to look at what the
individual vertices are and you can't
see it you can't possibly see it if you
squish it like like you've done there
like I've done here
yeah I mean like right like if you want
to zoom in and see what's going on at
the bottom you can't possibly do that
well but you can't do it here either yes
you can if you can grab it by the bottom
grab on the bottom two things you can
export it but also you can grab it by
right and then you can scroll
horizontally
oh well I see okay Charles that's
another issue why do we get the best
well how do we get the best of both
worlds for this well I mean there was
one thing we decided at the time when we
did do Tory for coffee is essentially to
you know as much as possible not change
the default Catholic options right
except this is using aspect ratio to
automatic which is I see the graphics
options
the graphics options um especially
because people combine and manipulate
things so more you change more stuff
yeah well fair enough
maybe I'm crystals argument is not a
terrible one III not really noticed this
this effect here okay so what are the
include event what are you saying credit
event instances this is where you'll see
it differs from the next graph output
right so that's showing multiple events
now if I were to say evolution events
graph which didn't do layering but this
is now showing I see
I say can I say I just have to say
layered graph plot there right so that's
now showing the events that's pretty
nice
yeah so sorry I think I was saying is a
multi-way function system as SPECT is
just the nest graph case right yes it is
so but that's just multi way system with
a state evolution function and
everything else unspecified that's not
interesting you can I mean like this you
can do that easily the the interesting
part is you have to you know differ is
defining event functions and
decomposition functions and things which
is domain-specific so like in the case
of so I've modified this slightly so it
so it deals specifically with the case
of functions over the integers because
then at least you that there is a
meaningful sense in which you can
construct an event decomposition
function so is there a reason why the
this sort of I don't want to call the
ruled vertices the orange-yellow
vertices is the reason why they're not
just edge annotations like the found an
argument to directed edge well they
could be but I mean that they're yet
more things that that the the main
reason was to support evolution causal
graph
because we wanted to have the events
also be connected by stuff like this
this okay and there isn't
we couldn't find a straightforward way
of doing that but I agree that there
could be an option to just have the
event be but I think if we say
eeveelution events graph structure oh
that's still extra nodes yeah I mean
there is a way you could do it because
for you know obviously for each event
you can get its actual event
specification and then you could just
overlay that on top of the edge but we
don't you could do it manually but we we
could also add an option for that all
right so the issue here is in general
we've got many different functions that
can appear as the first argument
and we've got look it seems to me we've
got special cases like substitution
system well what does substitution
system do if I were to give it like this
substitution system here and I say
substitution system and I just used that
ok now I apply that to a what do I get
that's bad example let's apply it to a a
a a why does it do that oh because it's
not a multi-way it's not the most native
case yeah oh my gosh so I see so really
the multi way thing is a headdress of
substitution system right it's not it's
saying it should be saying if we did
this with multi way system now and we
just did even just one step
can we do this yeah we can do this right
splat for does that don't mean why did
it do that great example of a case where
okay so there we go
so that is showing in that case all four
of the different rewrites that were
possible for a a a but see now multi way
system is using magic can the fact that
it knows about substitution system like
so yeah all right here but in general
its using magic to label for example
which rule is being applied where for
sure yes yes and it's also using magic
even to figure out I mean nest cough
couldn't do this because nest cough has
no way to get all the outputs from the
substitution system it only has a way to
get um well no this is nest list what
you've done right here is probably just
nest list yes right I mean if I were to
say if I were to put the graph thing
here if I were to say states graph right
the problem
this information substitution system
just applied as a function to this will
only give one result namely this right
and and the point even if it didn't even
if it gave multiple results that would
only be sufficient to define a state
evolution function so you could
construct a nest graph from it but you
couldn't construct a multi-way system
from it right and so you're saying we
have a dictionary a places where we know
what the event decomposition function is
and all those kinds of things right
look my main conclusion is is quite a
lot of design um and I think we're not
gonna get it done right now I mean the
yeah thickened milk Brancheau graphs
would be useful yeah I agree
by the way just in the in the in the
space of things I've been looking at
Combinator's and what I realized is that
there is a notion of spaces for
combinators as yet unworked out that
will allow us to have the whole same
formalism i mean beyond just the tree
form yes yes there's a notion of space
as in in defining and defining the
evaluation front evaluation front you
essentially are getting a foliation that
gives you instantaneous kind of notions
of space yeah I mean you can you can
represent the Combinator as a tree form
yeah which tree you get depends on which
foliation you're using that's true of
any multi way system you know every
space like hyper so now finds a
different expression I'm aware I'm well
I'm just that why is it specific to the
Combinator case
because in the hundred years that
combinators have existed it has not been
studied for Combinator's that's the only
reason it's we've discovered it hasn't
even been studied for integers so it
looks like not entirely surprising well
fair enough
by the way I studied for matrices
yesterday as well that has a whole
nother wild cool well the character um
yeah the the multi wavefunction system
for the integer case the the canonical
way I could think of doing it because
obviously in order to define it event
decomposition functions you need to have
a notion of elements because you need to
know what you know where elements got
created where they got destroyed and so
on right yes what I mean so so my
approach I tried two approaches one was
to look at individual digits as elements
which seems completely crazy
yep and the other which seems slightly
less crazy was to look at prime
factorizations and to basically treat
the prime factorization like why are you
doing that I don't know some why do you
need an event decomposition function of
that type I mean isn't this good enough
that this is just saying 9 turns into 14
and 12 yeah but this is nothing you
couldn't have done with nest growth the
power of multi-way system comes in these
things that aren't the state evolution
function like the event decomposition
function whether you use the event
decomposition function or causal
dependency need to know like causal
dependency hmm because cooler is a
tenancy there's an interesting a space
like causal dependency but there is your
you know you're breaking it out in terms
of well no no you you're saying that a
subpart of nine a subpart of 14 you know
a subpart of nine is what affects 14
well all of the events yes so what you
what you have to look at is so the you
know the way I'm currently structuring
it as you say we're applying this
function to this integer this function
has a prime factorization which you know
which prime factors were created by
which prior events that is wild it seems
to be the canonical way of doing it for
integers
I think it's totally weird I mean I
think it's look I think what's it what's
the old census
you
I don't I don't see one I don't know I'm
not sure there is another like ever but
but that this is a concept of breaking
this is what I talked about space it's a
concept of like for a Combinator it's
fairly straightforward it's got a whole
giant expression and you can look at the
sub pieces of that expression and see
but the problem here is which I'm
thinking of in general and some type of
space but the problem here is that
there's no obvious way that this thing
is broken into sub parts but there isn't
it's I mean unique factorization do we
what about complex numbers
but why do we wanna break it in the
subparts
to do a vent decomposition
because you want the event to be related
to a sub part of the object which I
think may not be doable in this case
okay well I mean it is sound makes sense
in this case because into the sardonic
design no they're not I show us an
example where where it will break it
into by factorization what do I ask Roja
we should get the causal growth that is
we we've been blessed by one of them
we've been blessed by one of the very
few fields that satisfies unique
factorization I agree if we if we wants
to make it work for like sickle atomic
antigens or something it'd mean like
we'd be in trouble but you can't be
serious that this is this is based on
prime factorization
I believe this version is yet I tried a
few different versions um that's surely
it's not a unique way of doing it no for
sure not and we need some other Andree
on the live stream saying cynthia is an
alternative prime factorization um if
there isn't prices don't know I don't
know um if he means like so if there is
in some of eratosthenes no I don't
suspect some other type of sieve but um
that's why I hadn't even thought about
the causal graphs for these things um
okay well done yeah you've got them okay
um I have to go to another meeting
unfortunately I we really need to
continue this um I apologize for cutting
it short just to comment force it on a
live stream these are these are graphs
that we're generating by algorithms
these are not graphs that represent for
example knowledge of the world these are
these are very much things that are
being generated all right I
unfortunately have to go to my other
meeting um and I know I'm following up
with you guys certainly Max and possibly
Jonathan later yes
um okay sorry got to go talk to you all
soon then right bye